global national with donna friesen
[Music]
the modern elizabethan era is over queen
elizabeth ii the longest reigning
monarch in history has died and as the
news spread today this rainbow appeared
over buckingham palace
people are gathered there britain is now
in a period of national mourning
queen elizabeth ii
was the rock on which modern britain was
built
our country has grown and flourished
under her reign
britain
is the great country it is today because
of her
and millions across the world share the
sadness and are sharing their memories
of her
as her
12th
canadian prime minister
i'm having trouble believing
that my last sit down with her
was my last
i will so miss those chats
she was
thoughtful
wise
curious
helpful
funny
and so much more
the american president joe biden offered
his condolences saying the queen led
always with grace and unwavering
commitment to duty and the incomparable
power of her example
all of her children and her grandson
prince william flew to scotland to be by
her side before the palace announced the
96 year old died peacefully this
afternoon at balmoral castle her beloved
scottish home
the crown has now passed to her son who
will be known as king charles iii
in a statement he called it a moment of
the greatest sadness for me and all
members of my family
good evening and thanks for joining us
we all knew she was in the final chapter
of her reign she'd been queen for seven
decades and she'd worked right up until
the very end meeting the uk's new prime
minister just this past tuesday she was
always there
and now
she is no longer tonight the world is
mourning the passing of her majesty
our coverage begins with our europe
bureau chief crystal gamansing in london
crystal
donna yeah the world really is mourning
and no more sign of that is around the
palaces in london at buckingham palace
you saw some pictures a little bit
earlier there's just rows and rows of
people flowers you know it's incredibly
late here in london but it is still very
very busy people just want to come
together they want to be around one
another share stories and have this
sense of community because truly their
sense of community has been rocked this
has been for most
taken away now it's not a matter of
shock she was 96 so people knew that
this was going to happen but it is still
profoundly sad and and people are trying
to come to grips with it
we did hear from the new prime minister
liz trust who just this week was you
know hand in hand with the queen as she
was asked to form a new government
here's what she had to say
through thick and thin
queen elizabeth ii
provided us with the stability and the
strength that we needed
she was the very spirit of great britain
and that spirit will endure
she has been our longest ever reigning
monarch
it's an extraordinary achievement to
have presided with such dignity and
grace for 70 years
her her life of service
stretched beyond most of our living
memories
in return she was loved and admired by
the people in the united kingdom
and all around the world
she has been a personal inspiration to
me
and to many britons
her devotion to duty is an example to us
all
crystal queen elizabeth took over from
her father george v and now
uh
her son is taking over from her
i guess we have to get used to saying
king charles now what has the new king
said about his mother's death
yeah king charles it's definitely
different to say and we're hearing a lot
of people now saying god save the queen
we expect based on reuters reports that
we will hear from king charles tomorrow
but he did release a statement today
sort of trying to calm the nation and
share some thoughts saying we mourn
profoundly the passing of a cherished
sovereign and much-loved mother i know
her loss will be deeply felt throughout
the country the realms and the
commonwealth goes on to say during this
period of mourning and change my family
and i will be comforted and sustained by
the our knowledge of the respect and
deep affection in which the queen was so
widely held we can also report that at
least one of uh king charles's titles
has been now handed to prince william he
will also be known as the duke of
cornwall in addition to being called the
duke of cambridge donna all right
crystal commansing in london thank you
all across canada flags on government
buildings including the peace tower in
ottawa have been lowered to half-mast
she was of course the queen of canada
too she met so many canadian prime
ministers
so many ordinary canadians as well on
her many trips here david aiken has been
following the prime minister who is in
vancouver david
yeah that's true donna she had a special
relationship with many people places
across the country i'm in one i'm
standing in christ church cathedral in
downtown vancouver it's right across the
street from the hotel where justin
trudeau and his cabinet have been
meeting for the last three days this is
an anglican church and it is a church
where elizabeth herself prayed in 1951
she was princess elizabeth when she
visited then and in fact her son the
king king charles he prayed here as well
when he visited in 1986 so this
cathedral when the news was announced
that the the queen had passed the doors
were open there's been a book of
condolences here that many people have
signed and the church bell told 96 times
in honor of the memory of queen
elizabeth now as for the pm and his
cabinet they did conclude their their
business their uh retreat but by and
large the business of government has
been paused as the pm reflected on a
queen that he first met for the first
time in
1977 as a boy at the side of his dad
pierre trudeau
she was our queen
for almost half of canada's existence
and she had an obvious
deep
and abiding love
and affection for canadians
she served us all with strength
and wisdom
for 70 years
as we grew into the diverse
optimistic
responsible
ambitious and extraordinary country we
are today
in
a complicated world
her steady grace
and resolve
brought comfort and strength to us all
canada
is in mourning
she was one of my favorite people in the
world
and i will miss her so
you know donna canada has only ever had
23 prime ministers in our entire
existence and more than half of them
12 including justin trudeau called
elizabeth their queen donna she has just
been around for so long david aiken in
vancouver thank you well canada's 20th
prime minister jean-claude had a very
special relationship with the queen that
spanned more than 50 years and continued
long after he left office the right
honorable jean cruz joins me now from
toronto mr cretcha you knew the queen
better than most of us how are you
feeling tonight
oh it's a very sad day but it was
expected because she was
96 years old but i met her in 1967 the
first time
when she came for the centennial of
canada and i had occasion to accompany
her in some ceremony and i
kept meeting her as minister and as
prime minister over the years i traveled
many days in the north for the
centennial of the northwest territories
in 1970
with prince philip prince charles and
princess anne
with her and
i have a lot of memories
and i met her in canada many times i met
her in
many places in
great britain i met her in different
commonwealth countries at commonwealth
meeting
so it's uh
55 years some well at least that i know
her and
it's a big big lust for everybody
millions of people around the globe are
very sad at this moment
you know so many people have talked
about her sense of humor i'm sure you
saw flashes of that over the years
oh but you know it is well known for
example that
when i signed a constitution
after trito
i when i took the pen the tip of the pen
was broken and when i tried to sign on
this very important
document
i could not then had been broken
so i said something
and the queen looked at the left look at
the right and bursting a big laugh
and i refused to say to the press what i
had said
but eventually i would say that's a
state secret but in fact i had said
merde and she had understood
that word because she was perfectly
bilingual and you know she laughed and
another occasion that was funny she was
one journalist in quebec and managed to
call her pretending that it was jean
crizzie
and
it was a
crazy interview
and she was polite
she the guy used terrible words she you
know and she kept
the dignity
that is a character characteristic of
her personality
but when i met earl a few days later in
new zealand
and i said your majesty i apologize for
the incident in quebec
when you had to we are confronted with a
very unusual
and she said oh yes i found that you are
not as usual and i thought you were
drunk she said to me
and just to show
how colorful and understanding she was
but she had been trapped by somebody was
quite smart to manage to cheat the
buckingham palace staff to pretend that
it was she was talking with her prime
minister of canada
well thank you for sharing those
memories i'm sure she was very
knowledgeable
and very
you know it was always
she was very interested of what was
going on in canada you know as i lived
some difficult time on national unity it
was a subject that many many times
i
discussed with her and she was offering
her support for a strong united canada
all the time
well former prime minister jean-claude
thank you so much for sharing your
memories and your time with us
thank you for calling and inviting me
thank you very much
within moments of the announcement of
the queen's death a crowd began to
gather outside buckingham palace
thousands of people coming together to
say goodbye to the only monarch many of
them have ever known
redmond shannon is there for us tonight
well donna it's
late in the evening here in london now
but still
people are here at buckingham palace i
would estimate maybe a couple of
thousand of course the world's media
gathering here too but people just want
somewhere to come somewhere to
share somewhere to talk somewhere to
express their sorrow and and their grief
although it was expected
uh given the news we heard earlier today
people are still in shock here in london
and when i was
out with a camera earlier today people
came up to me they saw the canadian flag
on my camera and they said we want to
tell you how we feel here's how here's
what a couple of them said to me
she was part of my life i've i'm 63 and
i remember the queen when i was
i think
from a child and what a wonderful
beautiful lovely queen she was what a
great spirit we've always been brought
up with a queen you know god saved the
queen in it that's that's the saying the
british saying so
kind of takes the great out of great
britain
there are now donna some people have
come out of the pubs and it is a little
rowdier shall we say it a little noisier
here by buckingham palace but earlier we
saw something more solemn with london's
famous black cabbies parking here and a
procession of those black cabs lined up
the mall the road that leads up to
buckingham palace what a week it's been
for this country with a new prime
minister and now a new monarch king
charles iii who will be quite
a few weeks ahead
donna huge changes in the uk redmond
shannon thanks
in june the queen celebrated her
platinum jubilee marking her 70 years on
the throne we're back with more on her
death and her legacy in a moment
the queen traveled to more than 100
countries and the place she visited the
most was canada she did 22 royal tours
here covered vast territory in this
country and met all kinds of people eric
sorenson joins me from toronto eric the
queen made so many connections here tell
us more about those
well donna the queen's reign spanned 12
of the 23 prime ministers in this
history in the history of this country
so more than half
since the beginning of confederation so
it's quite a record that she had with
almost half of the prime or more than
half of the prime ministers in the
country the first of course was louis
celeron starting in 1952
he met with the queen in a formal
picture that's him directly to her left
and there's winston churchill right on
her right so it shows you how far back
this goes
uh john diefenbaker was next he loved
the traditional symbols of british rule
in canada so much so that he wanted to
retain the red ensign with the emblem of
the union jack as our flag
it was lester pearson of course who
brought in the new red maple leaf flag
and he welcomed the queen for canada's
100th birthday at expo 67 canadians
celebrated being a nation unto
themselves
long before of course there was proper
recognition of indigenous people in this
country pierre trudeau met the queen
with young children including justin in
the 1970s and with the queen trudeau
signed the constitution act in 1982
establishing rights and freedoms that
continue to define our values and who we
are
joe clark wasn't in office long enough
to meet the queen but he was an
opposition leader when he met her in
this picture here john turner was only
in office briefly his connection was to
princess margaret they were an item and
it was thought they might marry way back
in around 1960. brian mulroney had a
unique relationship he was a leading
force to sanction south africa to end
apartheid he did not have the full
support of uk prime minister thatcher or
u.s president reagan though they opposed
apartheid but he had the strong and
quiet support of the queen while rooney
credits queen elizabeth for helping to
free south africa and nelson mandela
kim campbell did not have a royal visit
while in office that was a quick
turnover of three prime ministers in
that one year in 1993.
jean cretchen and the queen got on well
as he was telling you earlier donna that
that wonderful anecdote with the quebec
prankster and the queen ultimately
telling him she thought it was him on
the phone and thought he was drunk and
they laughed about that
paul martin met with the queen in 2005.
of course his father paul martin senior
also met with the queen way back when he
was external affairs minister prime
minister harper met with the queen both
at buckingham palace and in canada one
thing they shared was a love of the
canadian north both made more than one
trip to the arctic and justin trudeau
said the queen was one of his favorite
people we heard him earlier a sincere
sentiment as he has known her most
almost all of his life and here you see
the picture the queen is wearing a dress
with blue and yellow and the flowers
behind her are blue and yellow and that
seemed to be a clear signal just after
the war in ukraine had begun that she
was wearing and showing the colors of
that country and the queen of course
never betrayed a political position but
maybe just that once she did there so so
the queen met most of the 12 prime
ministers who served under her in canada
donna and she really had a warm
relationship with all of them and with
canadians
you know i heard eric from one royal
watchers that jean-claude was her
favorite canadian prime minister i have
no idea if that's true but apparently
because of his sense of humor and she
loved to laugh eric in toronto thanks so
much
she was the matriarch of the uk and in
many ways to the whole world no other
person on the world stage alive today
can come close to matching her longevity
and the vast number of historic events
she's witnessed warm tributes are
pouring in from leaders across the
political spectrum abigail beeman is
with me from ottawa with a look at some
of that abigail
well donna we're hearing from canadian
leaders who had a front seat to both
pivotal and private moments with the
queen beginning with former prime
minister brian mulrooney in office just
four days before he hosted her on a
visit to canada
she was
resolute and determined
very engaging
quite lovely
and very kind she was a towering figure
in history
a decade later paul martin became the
10th of 12 prime ministers during the
queen's reign and remembers her
unmistakable affection for canada as
well as her touching ability to build
relationships noting at their first
meeting she mentioned her friendship
with martin's parents who lived in
london while mr martin senior served as
high commissioner in the 1960s governor
general mary simon touched on a few
important themes in her message noting
the queen's belief in service to her
people above all and dedication to the
crown as well as the fact she's the only
queen most people ever knew tributes
continue to pour in from so many with
both historic and personal connections
remembering the queen's affection for
canada humility wisdom and sense of
humor donna all right abigail beeman in
ottawa thank you
we're back with more on the death of the
queen in a moment
queen elizabeth was 96 years old she
worked right up until the very end
seeing in the uk's new prime minister
just back on tuesday an entire
generation has known no other queen of
england it's impossible to condense her
long life into just a few minutes but
jeff semple has this look at some
pivotal moments
[Music]
in an ever-changing world she was a rock
of
stability queen elizabeth ii famously
said she had to be seen to be believed
and over seven decades with each passing
milestone thousands turned out to see
britain's oldest longest reigning and
most beloved monarch he's probably the
most famous woman in the world probably
the most admired woman in the world her
reign was as long as it was unexpected
born elizabeth alexandra mary on april
21
1926 she was still a child when her
uncle king edward viii abdicated the
throne
suddenly elizabeth's father was king and
she was next in line
the young princess made this promise i
declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service that
devotion to duty would be her hallmark
she was a teenager when europe went to
war and begged her father to let her
help first with her wartime radio
broadcast thousands of you in this
country have had to leave your home
and be separated from your fathers and
mothers
my sister
margaret rose and i
feel so much for you
and later joining the services as a
driver and mechanic during the war she
had a chance encounter with her distant
cousin philip he was serving with the
british royal navy in the mediterranean
and pacific they exchanged letters for
seven years as onto the famous balcony
came the bride and bridegroom the
newlyweds never expected princess
elizabeth was about to become queen but
when elizabeth's father died from a
heart attack the 25 year old was thrust
onto the throne
her coronation was one of the first
televised public events the young queen
quickly showed a knack for protecting
tradition while embracing change i very
much hope
that this new medium will make my
christmas message more personal and
direct
but the rise of technology also meant
the world was shrinking and so too was
her empire more than 25 countries
declared independence during her reign
others loosened their ties like canada
signing its constitution in 1982
her reign spanned 14 british and 12
canadian prime ministers from pierre
trudeau's famous pirouette to canada's
second prime minister trudeau thank you
mr prime minister of canada for making
me feel so old
many credit the queen's personal
popularity for the monarchy's survival
but at times she struggled to hold the
family together three of her children
divorced
and after the death of princess diana in
1997 the queen faced criticism for
failing to join the public outpouring of
grief
in february 2020 diana's youngest son
prince harry and his wife megan retired
from royal duties dealing a blow to the
palace
and a couple of months later the royal
family lost another member
prince philip died peacefully at windsor
castle at the age of 99. at his funeral
a scaled-down affair in the covid19
pandemic the queen sat alone in the pew
a widow after 73 years of marriage
but within days of her husband's death
her majesty was back to work holding
virtual royal audiences due to the
pandemic and as always keeping calm and
carrying on
one of the last times the family
appeared altogether was to mark her
platinum jubilee celebrating 70 years on
the throne
and despite scandals surrounding some of
her children grandchildren even the
british prime minister
the queen as ever seemed to rise above
making a surprise appearance on the
balcony of buckingham palace
her legacy will endure
but for a woman who steered the royal
family through three quarters of a
century
it's hard to imagine this place without
her
that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with more moments from britain
as the country and the rest of the world
mourn the passing of queen elizabeth ii
she endured for 70 years was there at
times of great crisis and great
celebration and it's unlikely the
monarchy will be the same without her
thanks for watching
bye
[Music]